pour voir les deux côtés de la médaille
avec Marc-André plante et les directeurs
des affaires publiques des relations
gouvernementales à la corporation des
propriétaires immobiliers du Québec la
corpique et Martin Blanchard copporte du
regroupement des comités logements et
associations de locataires du Québec
bonsoir à tous les deux bonsoir je vais
commencer avec vous monsieur Blanchard
et on va peut-être pouvoir revoir les
chiffres d'entrée de jeu justement qui
ont été dévoilés par le tribunal
administratif du logement on dit
ose de 2,3% pour les logements non
chauffés selon le type de chauffage là
on parle de jusqu'à 8 pour cent comment
vous réagissez à ces cibles-là qui ont
été dévoilées on réagit avec inquiétude
parce que c'est certainement des hausses
salées comme on mentionnait au début de
l'émission que vont recevoir les
locataires et comme il a été spécifié ce
sont des estimations de ce que serait
une hausse acceptée au tribunal s'il y
avait contestation c'est un peu ça le
rôle des indices c'est d'informer les
locataires sur un outil qui leur permet
de vérifier si la hausse proposée par le
propriétaire est raisonnable et est-ce
que ça vaut la peine de la contester ou
non mais on sait que d'année en année
les propriétaires ou en fait des
propriétaires proposent des roses
beaucoup de loin supérieurs aux indices
qui sont proposés et même de loin
supérieurs à l'inflation ce qui fait
qu'en règle générale les loyers vont
augmenter deux fois plus vite que
l'inflation le double de l'inflation et
ça année après année ça Gruse dans le
portefeuille des locataires et on est
rendu un point où c'est rendu difficile
au niveau des loyers très bien monsieur
plante vous qu'est-ce que vous déplorez
là avec ces taux d'ajustement vous
considérez que c'est pas suffisant que
certains propriétaires vont même devoir
absorber certains coups à l'évidence
dans la dernière année
l'inflation dans le secteur de la
construction est à environ 7% alors
nécessairement par les chiffres
présentés par le tribunal ce sont des
simulations qui sont en deçà de
l'inflation vous savez que les
simulations du tribunal une stratif au
cours des 20 dernières années sont
systématiquement en deçà de l'inflation
donc il faut faire attention avec toutes
sortes de méthodes de calcul de dire que
les propriétaires n'absorbent pas une
partie de l'inflation donc il faut le
dire les propriétaires sont même si la
hausse elle est parmi les plus élevées
au cours des 10 dernières années ceux-ci
vont quand même absorber une part de
l'inflation pas tout le monde évidemment
pas tous les propriétaires qui auront
fait des travaux par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont tenter de refiler là comme
facture alors locataires les taxes
municipales les primes d'assurance qui
sont en très forte hausse depuis
quelques années sauf le souligner c'est
un exemple il faut aussi ajouter que ce
qu'on critique beaucoup à la CORPIQ dans
la méthode de calcul c'est qu'on
reconnaît mal finalement les travaux
majeurs vous savez que pour une dépense
de 1000 dollars l'impact direct sur le
loyer va être en réalité de trois
dollars 27 années alors l'amortissement
va se faire sur 26 ans en excluant
évidemment les frais d'intérêt alors si
on veut un parc locatif qui est
entretenu qu'on va protéger à long terme
il faut nécessairement l'investir
surtout dans l'objectif de le décarboner
pour qu'éventuellement il y a plus
d'huile à chauffage dans le parc locatif
ça c'est un autre objectif cela dit bon
on a vu ce qui a été dévoilé par le
tribunal administratif du logement vous
monsieur Blanchard il y a certainement
des gens qui vont vous dire mon
propriétaire tente de me refiler une
hausse de loyer abusive qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qui est abusé comment on
détermine que c'est une hausse abusive
c'est lorsque c'est au-dessus du 2,3% et
c'est important que les locataires et
les propriétaires se partagent les coûts
liés à l'inflation à l'entretien on ne
peut pas la partie locataire ne peut pas
absorber tous les coups liés à
l'inflation et le calcul c'est de faire
un équilibre entre les les frais que
doivent se partager les uns et les
autres et c'est ce qui fait que les
propriétaires lorsqu'ils revendent leur
immeuble bien entretenu ils ont quand
même un énorme profit que les locataires
ne touchent pas donc
normal qu'à au niveau du risque qu'on
assume une partie des coûts c'est tout à
fait normal et c'est calcul là sont en
absence très équilibré alors quand on
essaie de battre l'inflation ou même
qu'on essaye d'être au niveau de
l'inflation on est en train de
déséquilibrer le système de la même
façon les travaux majeurs oui c'est
amorti sur plusieurs années mais les
propriétaires profitent d'un abattement
fiscal lorsqu'ils font des travaux
majeurs et ensuite la hausse sur les
travaux majeurs elle est permanente elle
va continuer de sévir même lorsque les
travaux seront remboursés donc lorsqu'on
va au-delà des indices qui sont publiés
par le tal on est dans une zone abusive
et malheureusement c'est généralement le
cas où c'est souvent le cas puisque
année après année les chefs publiés par
la SCHL montrent que les loyers montent
plus haut que l'inflation
entre vous deux c'est à dire tout le
monde on a avantage est-ce que les
logements soient bien entretenus à
l'avantage du locataire d'avoir un
logement en bon état c'est à l'avantage
du propriétaire aussi d'investir et
d'assurer la valeur de son actif si vous
voulez est-ce que il y a un terrain
d'entente possible
je pense que quand dans un parc locatif
au Québec ou 60 % des logements ont été
construits avant 1980 il est clair qu'un
déficit donc dans l'entretien de
celui-ci on a un parc locatif qu'on a
besoin de protéger et de réinvestir
problème c'est qu'avec la hausse des
taux d'intérêt ce qu'on anticipe du côté
de la pchq au niveau de la rénovation
2023 c'est une baisse de 15% qui
équivaut à 3 milliards de dollars alors
nous ce qu'on dit c'est qu'il faut
trouver un équilibre si c'est à la fois
par des programmes gouvernementaux
notamment pour décarboner le parc
locatif c'est un bel exemple ça va venir
indirectement atténuer la facture sur
les loyers alors il faut être en mode
solution et aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit
c'est que la méthode de calcul qui
existe à donc de des résultats que nous
acceptons mais leur certains effets
pernicieux de ne pas encourager la
détention à long terme et aussi les
petits propriétaires qui sont plus
impactés à ce moment-ci par l'inflation
bon il y a un autre terrain d'entendre
c'est à dire que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord
la méthode de calcul elle permet de
faire un profit vraiment important dans
l'immobilier c'est ce qu'on va essayer
un des secteurs les plus profitables au
Canada il y a aucun il y a aucun frein
actuellement de faire de faire de
l'argent de façon importante au niveau
de l'immobilier et là ce que j'entends
c'est qu'on voudrait en faire plus
encore m'emmener de l'immobilier est en
train de mettre la pression sur
l'inflation et des donner un mauvais
élève au niveau économique il est en
train de pousser
de pousser les propriétaires
d'entreprise à être obligé de donner de
meilleurs salaires à leur travailleur
vous souhaiteriez monsieur Blanchard ce
soit ce serait que les taux
d'ajustements soient imposés comme
remarqué un contrôle obligatoire des
loyers qu'on respecte cet équilibre là
qui est proposé et qui est d'après moi
est très bien calculé et puis les
propriétaires qui veulent une hausse
supérieure à ce taux là qu'ils aient
justifié devant le tribunal ce qu'ils
veulent avoir d'abord je suis toujours
surpris d'entendre les suggestions du
réclaque de bar il y a un an il
réclamait un gel complet à zéro pour
cent des loyers en novembre dernier nous
ont préconisé un plafond d'augmentation
des loyers aujourd'hui ils veulent plus
de contrôle moi ce que je dis c'est que
les 250 000 propriétaires au Québec ils
veulent la prévisibilité ils veulent
savoir dans quel système on va
fonctionner et aujourd'hui il faut être
en mode donc solution il manque 100 000
logements dans le parc au Québec et
aujourd'hui il faut intéresser les
propriétaires investir à ce qui se
construisent plus de logements et
aujourd'hui quand on se compare
lorsqu'on a beau dire que ce soit un bon
ou un mauvais élève dans le reste du
Canada on paie beaucoup moins notre pour
se loger ici au Québec puis
malheureusement le propriétaire
dans même dynamique de rénovation et les
coûts de deux par 4 coûte le même prix à
Toronto qu'à Montréal alors faut faire
attention aujourd'hui de faire des
propositions qui vont déstabiliser et
impacter les locataires directement
c'est qu'il y a pas mal de litiges le
1700 litres dans des propriétaires des
locataires l'an dernier est-ce que c'est
un signe que le système de fixation des
prix lors du tribunal administratif du
logement ça fonctionne pas monsieur
blancheur
ça veut dire que les hausses que ont
reçu les locataires n'étaient pas
acceptables de leur point de vue et que
le propriétaire face au refus du
locataire est allé demander une fixation
de loyer c'est ça que ça veut dire on va
en avoir de plus en plus vous croyez en
2023 on en aura probablement en plus
puisque les mais pas à cause des
chiffres qui sont à cause de 2,3% à
cause qu'on voit le dépasser encore plus
parce qu'on est dans une on est dans une
logique spéculative actuellement on
essaie de battre l'inflation on essaie
de battre la bourse on essaie de faire
des profits extrêmes au niveau de
l'immobilier et si on veut vraiment
stabiliser les choses aussi l'intention
c'est d'avoir un système stable mais on
va aller vers un contrôle obligatoire
des loyers pour ce qui est du gel des
loyers j'aimerais informer mon mon
acolyte monsieur plante que c'est en
attendant qu'il y a un contrôle
obligatoire de loyer on va devoir
s'arrêter là-dessus je suis certaine que
vous allez poursuivre la discussion ou
sortir de cette entrevue et beaucoup de
défis clairement à la fois pour les
propriétaires et pour les locataires en
2023 merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'avoir été merci pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI